no solo
[Música]
tres años llegué a este mundo
siendo una niña diferente tan diferente
como mi nombre si buscan mi nombre en
google no vas a conseguir un significado
sin embargo yo le puse el significado el
nombre de mi papá y mi mamá que es un
pacto de amor por lo tanto de ahí nace
el nombre de esta charla porque a leiby
viene de un crecimiento de amor mi papá
se llama alejandro y mi mamá vino de ahí
salgo yo siendo una niña diferente que
hablaba mucho siempre estaba levantada
experimentando cosas nuevas corriendo
siendo muy muy muy activa fui criticada
y etiquetada por el entorno porque eso
no era lo que una niña tenía que estar
haciendo yo tenía que estar o la
sociedad decía que tenía que estar pues
sentada tranquila con vestido limpia
siendo educada no podía dejar la voz y
de acuerdo a lo que la sociedad me iba
diciendo pues me iba sintiendo cada vez
menos aceptada de acuerdo a mis
habilidades sin embargo pues crecí en un
ambiente de artistas
toqué el piano cante de muchos años
toqué la flauta estudia música baile
practica natación gané muchas medallas
jugué básquet voleibol etc ese era mi
mundo ese era mi talento sin embargo
pues cuando me tocaba estar en esta
parte de la educación o de lo que
debería ser para tener un futuro en ser
artista no formaba parte de ese mundo
que siendo artista no llegaría a ningún
lado siendo artista no tendría un
trabajo estable por lo tanto a medida
que voy creciendo pues voy dejando a un
lado todo este mundo para poder
enfocarme más en todo lo que son las
matemáticas la física la química
etcétera cuando tengo 15 años tengo mi
primer trabajo
era para la cita de fiestas animaba
fiestas y me di cuenta de que el que yo
hablara y fuera tan emocionada si
cambiaba el estado de ánimo de las
personas eso quiere decir que lo que yo
hacía no era que estaba mal sino que no
ocupaba el lugar en el mundo que tenía
que ocupar afortunadamente me doy cuenta
que pude desarrollarme y sergio que los
aplausos después de un espectáculo era
lo que me llenaban que ya no tenía que
ser esa niña que se portara bien sino
que podía animar una fiesta y hacer que
todo el mundo disfrutará del ambiente
empecé a reconocer cuáles eran las
habilidades que tenía y dejé de
criticarme juzgarme y etiquetarme
estas habilidades me llevaron a
descubrir que si podía estudiar algo que
me llevara a explotar eso que llevaba en
luz entonces es cuando empieza a
estudiar relaciones públicas
afortunadamente esa carrera me cambió la
vida pude estar en el lugar que tenía
que estar pude distinguir me identifiqué
que cuando me ubicaba en lugares en los
que no podía desarrollarme o no tenían
las habilidades pues definitivamente no
iba a poder crecer y lo que hacía era
frustrar me desde allí me di cuenta que
quería seguir estudiando muchas cosas
más
estudié fotografía aunque sabía que no
iba a ser una fotógrafa profesional
definitivamente desarrollar habilidades
en la fotografía estudié cosmetología
estudié en la mejor academia del mundo
del maquillaje semipermanente y pude
con mi calidad de servicio con esto que
traemos adentro que me encantaba
monetizarlo y pude ganar dinero con todo
este talento me di cuenta de que un
momento de la vida que sentía que no
sabía para dónde iba estudiaba
demasiadas cosas hacía muchísimas cosas
y no identificaba cuál era el propósito
sin embargo lo que hice en búsqueda del
desarrollo personal y conseguir mi
centro lo que hice fue hacer una fusión
de todos mis conocimientos y actualmente
monetizarlo y trabajar me certifique
como coach personal porque me di cuenta
que me encantaba ayudar a las personas
estudié educación porque me di cuenta
que me encantaba compartir mis
conocimientos y hoy en día puedo dar
cursos educar dar coaching apoyarte en
todos los emprendimientos que tengas que
piensas que no los puedes lograr o en
todos estos miedos o en todas estas
creencias limitantes que también he
tenido
vuelto a estar estos procesos que
pensamos que no nos van a llevar a
ningún lado
por todas
como conocida
que se escuchó por ejemplo
el ser coche me dio la oportunidad de
definitivamente desarrollar muchísimas
más habilidades en mí y por supuesto
trabajarlo también en mi ámbito como
mujer hoy en día soy mamá de un hermoso
galán y de dos hermosas princesas y en
ser mamá me hizo entrar en el juego de
las serpientes y las escaleras porque a
veces estamos muy arriba y a veces
creemos que todo está perfecto sin
embargo en cada uno de mis embarazos era
como quería ahora para dónde voy ahora
cuál es el proyecto que viene ahora en
donde invierte este tiempo por lo tanto
el hecho de de tener todos estos cambios
en mi vida de cambiar de país de venirme
desde venezuela de ser aquí una
inmigrante me ayudó a desarrollar
muchísimas más destrezas a aprender algo
nuevo cada día y haberme desde el amor
porque cuando no me veía no creía en él
y esperaba que el entorno me dijera cuál
era mi destino que me dijera cuál era mi
rol en el mundo que me dijera cuál era
que tenía que cumplir hoy te invito a
que rompas con todos esos paradigmas con
toda esta sociedad que te dice quién
tiene que ser como mujer
si tienes que parar si para ser una
buena mamá tienes que estar en casa todo
el día con los niños sí para ser una
buena mamá tienes que dejar a un lado
tus sueños y estar en casa o puedes
conseguir un equilibrio entre entre
estos dos y también ser feliz tú
es muy importante que también te invito
a ver es que tengas tu concepto de éxito
muy claro ser exitoso para mí es amar lo
que hago y hacer con pasión lo que hago
sin embargo para muchas personas el
éxito es llegar de primero a competir y
hoy en día tú y yo sabemos que no
necesitamos competir para estar donde
queremos estar
identifica el lugar que quieres en el
punto reconoce ser vulnerable porque
para poder aprender tenemos que
reconocer con esa humildad que
necesitamos aprender y desarrollar
muchas cosas más
creo que este mundo del apoderamiento y
este power que tenemos que tener como
mujeres y creo que también como hombres
diario lo tenemos que desarrollar no se
trata de por todo mi trabajo personal o
por lo que yo hago tengo una vida
perfecta se siguen presentando
situaciones vividas con las cuales tengo
que aplicar herramientas que me ayuden a
sobrellevar las a llevarlas
a superarlas muchísimo mejor a utilizar
el miedo como plataforma y no que me
paralice porque siempre esto que estamos
haciendo aquí implica miedo implica
emociones pero como fluye pues aquí
estamos dejar fluir no quiere decir no
accionar y dejar que todo pase quiere
decir que acciones y que tomes
decisiones que tomes las riendas de tu
vida que tú decidas donde quieres estar
cómo quieres estar cuando quieres estar
sin lastimar a los demás amándote tú en
la muerte de ti ser feliz
[Música]